قالت وسائل اعلام اسرائيليه ان وزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي اجتمع بالسفير الامريكي
لدى اسرائيل واطلعه على سير العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه الجاريه في مخيم
جنين واضافت ان عمليه جنين تم التخطيط لها
منذ عام ووافق نتنياهو على تنفيذها قبل
عشره ايام وتم ابلاغ الامريكيين بها على
اعلى مستوى دون تحديد للموعد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الاعزاء كان ذاك خبر
حلقتنا ولنا في نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات
ما مضامين ودلالات احاطه وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي السفير الامريكي بمجريات
العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه في جنين
وكيف يبدو الموقف الامريكي من العمليه
العسكريه الاسرائيليه في جنين وكيف يرى
الجانب الفلسطيني موقع ودور واشنطن بين
الروايتين الاسرائيليه والفلسطينيه
والى ماذا قد تتطور الاوضاع الامنيه
والسياسيه في المنطقه واي مستقبل لجهود
التهدئه التي تقودها اطراف اهمها الولايات
المتحده بالنظر
لكل ذلك
[موسيقى]
مباشره الى كلمه لرئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياه
بجنين ومعبود
خصنين
انا
[موسيقى]
اخوكم مش بقى رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيليه
بنيامين نتنياهو يلقي كلمه يتطرق فيها
بطبيعه الحال لما يحصل في جنين والاوضاع
داخل مخيم جنين في ضوء العمليه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه التي تقول المعلومات ان
نتنياهو وافق عليها قبل عشره ايام
وكانت هذه الخطه قد اعدت قبل عام من اليوم
وقد بدا تنفيذها بعدما اخترت الولايات
واحده بهذه العمليه واهدافها
ويقول نتنياهو في هذه الكلمه ان جنين باتت
ملاذا لما يصفه بالارهاب
وانه سيضع حدا اليوم لذلك الارهاب من جنين
على حد تعبير نتنياهو في هذه الكلمه
واضاف ان جيشه الجيش الاسرائيلي قد بدا
عمليه واسعه في جنين
وكرايس وزراء ودوا ان اعبر عن امتنان
الحار
للدعم المستمر الامريكي الاسرائيلي 75
عاما الولايات المتحده الامريكيه كانت
حليفنا الذي لا يمكن الاستغناء عنه
استبداله
لا يمكن الاستغناء عنه ولا استعادته احد
عشر دقيقه بعد ولاده دولتنا وعلى منعطف
الطريق في تاريخنا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه زودت اسرائيل بالدعم السياسي
لاولئك الذين التزموا بابادتنا
وابادتنا كالدوله يهوديه واحده
ولاكثر من نصف قرن الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قد قدمت دعما
لاسرائيل وزودت نبي الادوات هي الادوات
التي نعنع بحاجه لها للدفاع عن انفسنا
بانفسنا
وعقدا باع قده عقد دولتين قد
عملت سويا مع بعضهم ويسرنا ان نقول اليوم
بان تعاوننا الامني لم يكن افضلا وتبادلنا
الاستخباراته لم يكن اعمق وتحالفنا لم يكن
اقوى
لطالما قلت بان اسرائيل لا حليفه افضل لها
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وانا اقول
لكم الان بان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لا حليفه افضل لها من اسرائيل
[تصفيق]
انا واثق بان اسرائيل مهمه للولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وقد اصبح هذا واضحا في
السنوات التي عملنا فيها سويا ليس فقط من
اجل حمايه امننا المشترك وايضا من اجل
تطوير افضل التكنولوجيا متطوره سوف
تساعدنا باعاده تشكيل القرن الواحد
والعشرين هم هذا ما سيقرب من سيقود العالم
واسرائيل هي الشريك اذا مشاهدينا نكتفي
بهذه الكلمه
الذي تحدث فيها عما يجري في
جنين وقال ان جيش الجيش الاسرائيلي قد بدا
عمليه في جنين واشاد بدعم الولايات
المتحده لاسرائيل وتقديمها لدعم العسكري
السخيل لاسرائيل كما قال في هذا الموضوع
لمناقشته ومناقشه علم الولايات المتحده
بما يج في جنين واختار اسرائيل مسبقا
للاداره الامريكيه بهذه العمليه معنى من
نابلس نواف العامر الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
ومن واشنطن الدكتور ادوارد جوزيف استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه جونز هوبكنز
وسبدا معك دكتور ادوارد جوزيف عن دلاله
حرص حكومه نتنياهو مع كل
ما يحكي عن ملابله في علاقته مع اداره
بايدن حرص هذه الحكومه اليوم على اخطار
الولايات المتحده بهذه العمليه مسبقا واخذ
ربما الضوء الاخضر قبل المباشره بتنفيذها
شكرا جزيلا على دعوه
اولا اود ان اقول قبل الاجابه عن ان
الماساه التي تجري الان في جنين اليوم
وفيها
ثمانيه فلسطينيين قتلوا وهي ماساه مهما
كان
ما هي اهدافهم وما وغير ذلك من المعطيات
رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو ما يحاول للقيام به
في كلمته هو ان يضع
العمل الاسرائيلي في سياق
معين في سياق العلاقات مع الولايات
المتحده
ويؤكد على كما قال على ان العلاقات لم تكن
بمثل هذه القوه
والعمل الاسرائيلي بطريقه التي نقلها الى
المتحده وانه يحظى بدعم بدعم الامريكي
واداره
بايدن تفعل كل ما يمكنها ان تفعله
للحد من
الطريقه التي تقوم بها اسرائيل بهذه
العمليه حتى يكون هناك اقل عدد من الخسائر
من الجانبين واداره بعيدا لا يريد ان يرى
تصعيدا
ومواجهات وفلوس المتحده لدينا مؤشرات على
ان هناك عملا
سيجري
واسرائيل تحاول ان تقوم بعمل بعمليتها
وتخرج سريعا بدون المزيد من العنف مثل ما
حدث في غزه او في لبنان وقد راينا
بيانات من الجهاد على ان عامل الزمن له
اهميته ذلك هو السياق الذي تحدث عنه رئيس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي
سيدنا نواف من وجهه نظرك كيف يمكن ان تفهم
هذا التواصل على اعلى مستوى قبل البدء
بالعمليه واعلام الولايات المتحده بها
خصوصا يعني اذا اخذنا بعني الاعتبار ما
قاله ضيفنا من واشنطن ان الولايات المتحده
تريد عمليه سريعه ولا تريد تصعيد واسع
اسعد الله اوقاتكم قبل ان اجيب على سؤالكم
لابد ان اعود الى الخلفيه التاريخيه للدعم
الامريكي للكيان الاسرائيلي وكما تحدث
نتنياهو في مؤتمر وقبل قليل اشار الى ان
الولايات المتحده اعترفت بقيام الكيان بعد
11 دقيقه من قيامه لكنه في الحقيقه ان
الولايات المتحده اعترفت بالكيان ثور
قيامه وفور الاعلان عنه تلاهى الاتحاد
السوفيتي بعد ثلاث دقائق من اعلان وما هم
الاشاره الى ان الدعم الامريكي من العام
1948 للكيان الاسرائيلي حتى منتصف العام
الماضي بدعم المالي والعسكري تجاوز 130
مليار تشكل ما نسبته 55% من الدعم العالمي
للكيان الاسرائيلي ايضا من المهم الاشاره
الى ان يعني من المهم ان تنال الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه جائزه نوبل في وقف في
قرارات حق النقد الفيتو التي استخدمت ثلاث
ثمانين الولايات المتحده نصفها كان ضد
القضيه الفلسطينيه
للقضيه الفلسطينيه
نعم فقط لكن كنت اود ان افهم منك كيف ترى
هذا التواصل حول هذه العمليه بالتحديد لان
لهذه العمليه قد تكون تداعيات ربما تتسع
اكثر ساعود اليك في للحديث عن هذه عن هذه
القضيه لكن في تفاصيل اوفى عن التواصل
الاسرائيلي الامريكي بشان عمليه جنين
صحيفه معاريفه العبريه نقلت عن مصدر
اسرائيلي تاكيده ان تل ابيب شاركت واشنطن
معلومات اساسيه بشان عمليه جنين على مستوى
رفيع للغايه ولم تحجب عنها سوى موعد
الانطلاق المصدر واضاف لصحيفه ان السلطات
الاسرائيليه حرصت على ابلاغ الامريكيين
بان عمليه جنين العسكريه ستكون عباره عن
غاره لها اهداف محدده ومعينه بدقه وان
الامر لا يتعلق بالسيطره على الارض
المصدر قال ان تل ابيب اكدت لواشنطن ان
عمليه جنين العسكريه لا تشبه في شيء ما
يحصل في غزه وقالت الصحيفه الاسرائيليه
معاريف ان الاداره الامريكيه وان اعربت عن
دعمها للعمليه فقد نقلت قلقها من احتمال
انزلاق الاوضاع الى تصعيد واسع يخلف
اصابات اكبر بين المدنيين
عن هذا الموقف اسال ضيفنا من واشنطن
الدكتور ادوارد لماذا يعني توافق الاداره
الامريكيه على عمليه من هذا النوع
تكتنف يعني
خطوره قد لا تكون منظوره للعيان
ليس لدينا تاكيد بان الولايات المتحده
وافقت على هذه العمليه ولكن اذا كان هناك
نوع من الموافقه فهي مرتبطه
بفهم
كما تقول اسرائيل عن طبيعه هذه العمليه
وعن الامكانات التي ستستخدم
وعن التوقيت والمده الزمنيه اذا كانت
الولايات المتحده تشعر بان هذه المعلومات
مبرره للتعامل مع منشات تصنع فيها
الاسلحه مثلا
وقد استخدمت مؤخرا وهي
سبب او تقف وراء اعمال عنف
فان الاسرائيليين يقولون
انها تعني اهدافا محدده
وسريعه للتعامل مع ذلك
التهديد العسكري
انذاك
ستكون اذا لا تثير الكثير من القلق
هناك ايضا
لا تعتقد ان هناك بقاء لوقت طويل هناك اذا
الطريقه التي قدمت بها اسرائيل هذه
العمليه اذا كانت هادفه ومركزه وسريعه
وسريعه جدا
للدخول التعامل مع المسائل الاسلحه ثم
الخروج طيب
يعني يعني وكان الولايات المتحده وضعت
عفوا كان الولايات المتحده قد وضعت خطوطا
عريضه واهدافا محدده وشروط لهذه العمليه
لكن من تداعيات ما يجري الان من تداعيات
هذا الموقف الامريكي تحديدا ان الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه قررت تقنين العلاقه مع
الولايات المتحده
اذا الرئاسه الفلسطينيه في بيان الله قررت
تقنين العلاقه مع الولايات المتحده وقررت
ايضا استمرار وقت التنسيق الامني وايضا
وقف الاتصالات واللقاءات مع الجانب
الاسرائيلي يعني التداعيات قد تكون اوسع
مما تريده الولايات المتحده ماذا لو اتسع
الموقف العسكري اكبر وتدحرجت الامور ماذا
ستفعل الولايات المتحده بعد ان اعطت
موافقتها الاوليه على عمليه جنين تفضل
[موسيقى]
ليس لدينا تاكيد بان هناك موافقه
رسميه او فعليه وما نعرفه هو ان اداره
بايدن واهتمامها هو تفادي اي تصعيد
الولايات المتحده لا تريد ان ترى اي
مواجهات واي مظاهر عنف واي خساره لارواح
الفلسطينيين
كما هو الحال الان فان امكانيه
تصعيد من بمشاركه الجهاد او الحماس في غزه
او حزب الله من لبنان هذا اخر ما تريده
الولايات المتحده فيما يتعلق بردود الفعل
السياسيه انا متاكدا ان هذه البيانات
والتصريحات من السلطه الفلسطينيه في رام
الله
وانها ينبغي ان تترك
القنوات مفتوحه
التصريح من الجهاد الاسلامي الذي يشير الى
وجود حد زمني
قد تتدخل وترد فيه على ما يحدث ذلك هو
البيان من الجهاد الاسلامي وهو لا يقول
انهم سوف يتدخلون حتى بين الفلسطينيين
يبدو ان هناك
افاده
وتوقعا ان تكون العمليه قصيره
جدا ومره اخرى لذلك من المهم ان
الاسرائيلي ينهو عمليتهم ويخرج ويحدوا من
اي خسائر في الارواح
وهذا ما ولا يحدث ما نسميه المتحده ان
يؤدي الى المزيد من التصعيد ينبغي على
اسرائيل
وتخرج منجلين باسرع وقت ممكن طيب سيدنا
كيف يبدو لك هذا الموقف
الامريكي والذي يعني عمليا اضاءت عليه
اسرائيل
قبل او مع بدايه هذه العمليه العسكريه
الكيان الاسرائيلي باستمرار يعول على
مواقف الادارات الامريكيه المتعاقبه لانه
يريد من الادارات الامريكيه او
الدبلوماسيه الامريكيه توفير غطاء سياسي
ودبلوماسي لجرائمها ولعملها العسكري في
الاراضي الفلسطيني او في حتى الدول
العربيه المحيطه وقد يعني
توضح ذلك في مقالته لداعي العبريه اليوم
ان مقدم الاخبار في سي ان ان الرئيسيه
يعني استخدم مصطلحات طلب منه ان يستخدمها
كقبيل من قبيل ما تطرق اليه وزير الجيش
الاسرائيلي نتنياهو انه نشاط وجهد وليس
عمليه عسكريه على غرار ما قالته
الخارجيه الروسيه في الحرب في اوكرانيا
رفضتها امريكا في اوكرانيا وقبلت فيها
بالساحه الفلسطينيه الادارات الامريكيه
عمليا يعني الجمهوريين هم يوافقوا على
استهداف الفلسطيني دون ودون البسمله
الادارات الديمقراطيه توافق على الاستهداف
الفلسطيني والحقوق الفلسطينيه بعد ان
يقراوا البسمله ويقيموا لنا طقوسا تليق
بدفننا ودفن قضيتنا الفلسطينيه عمليا ما
يجري يعني رغم ان هناك خلافات في العلن
بين الاداره الامريكيه برئاسه بايدن
وحكومه نتنياهو الا ان ما يحكم هذه
العلاقات ليست ليس الرؤساء بقدر ما يحكمها
المؤسسات الرسميه المتاثره في الايباك حيث
ان هناك عدد كبير من المؤثرين في الاداره
الامريكيه الجديده هي اصولهم يهوديه ومنهم
بلينكن وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه عمليا
الاداره الامريكيه تفضل عمل سريع في الضفه
الغربيه دون ان يتاثر ذلك ودون ان تمتد
الاحداث الى ساحات الضفه الغربيه الاخرى
وهي مخاوف عبر عنها الشابات وضباط كبار في
الجيش الاسرائيلي خشت ليس الى مدن وسط
الضفه الغربيه وجنوب الضفه الغربي ولكن
الى ان تمتد الى جغرافيه اكثر وابعد مثل
القطاع غزه كما هددت غرفه العمليات
المشتركه اليومي لكن يعني الغريب في في
هذه النقطه ايضا
ان هيئه البث الاسرائيليه ولابد انك تابعت
هذا الامر عندما نقلت عن مسؤولين
اسرائيليين بارزين ان تل ابيب لم تواجه
ضغوطا
دوليه فعليه حتى الان من اجل وقف هذه
العمليه او التحذير من العمليه او غير ذلك
يعني وكان هناك نوع من الضوء الاخضر
الممنوح لاسرائيل
وفسحه من الزمن ربما
صحيح يعني الاداره الامريكيه ومعها القاره
العجوز الاوروبيه يعني طوال فتره نشوء
اسرائيل الى اللحظه هي التي اوقفت اسرائيل
على قدميها واعتبرت الحبل السري للكيان
الاسرائيلي بامدادها بالمال والقوه
والعتاد والسلاح الى اخره والتاثير
الدبلوماسي الاسرائيلي المنتشر في الغرب
له تاثيره في النخب في السياسيين في
المثقفين في البرلمانات وفي الدول ولهم
حضور بذلك يقابله ضعف عربي رسمي فلسطيني
في الفعل الدبلوماسي لكن الاشارات التي
تقدمها الدبلوماسي الاسرائيلي والتواصل
الاسرائيلي كما فعل وزير الحرب الاسرائيلي
مع السفير الامريكي في في القدس وابلغه
بالعمليه وشرح له التفاصيل تشير الى انهم
يقدمون معلومات بسيطه يعني ظاهرا لكنهم
يشيرون ويقدمون معلومات يعني تجبر
الامريكيين على القبول بالعمل العسكري
الاسرائيلي لان الاسرائيلي رضيت امريكا او
لم ترضى فانه ذاهب الى عمليات يعني جراحيه
صغيره واللطيف يعني الخطير في نفس الوقت
ان الاستهداف هو لكيانات المخيمات
الفلسطينيه بجنين ونور شمس ومخيم بلاطه
وهذا يشير في دلاله الامر الى ان
الفلسطيني بعد 75 عام لم لم يستطع
الاسرائيلي حسب الصراع معه وانه حافظ على
حضوره وعلى هويته وعلى تواجده وانه صاحب
قضيه سواء رضي الامريكيان اراضيك الامريكي
او يعني خطا الرسمي العربي او لم يستطع
الفلسطيني الرسمي فعل شيء الامريكان بشكل
او باخر هم قلبا وقالبا مع الفعل
الاسرائيلي مع الاستهداف الفلسطيني لانهم
عندما يتحدثون لهم بكلمه ويتحدثون عن
الارهاب تصيبهم قشعريره على اعتبار ان
الكينونه الغربيه لديه حساسيه يعني مفرطه
من موضوع الارهاب وهذه المصطلح الذي يعني
بالاسف خرج من منطقتنا العربيه يعني
لو تبعنا الموقف او ما اعلن اسرائيليا عن
ابلاغ الولايات المتحده بالعمليه ثم
البيان الصادر عن البيت الابيض والذي يدعم
امن اسرائيل والحق في الدفاع عن نفسها
وامنها
يعني ذلك
موافقه واضحه صريحه وفعليه ولا يحرج ذلك
الولايات المتحده التي تقدم نفسها دائما
كراعي لعمليه سلام ووسيط وغير ذلك اين
اصبحت كل هذه المصطلحات عندما يعني توافق
بهذه بهذا الوضوح وهذه الصراحه الولايات
المتحده على عمليه تستهدف مخيما يقتلونه
لاجئون ومدنيون فلسطينيون
ردي على هذا السؤال ينبغي ان ننظر في سياق
معين اولا كما قلت الولايات المتحده لا
مصلحه لها في ان ترى الاسرائيليين يقتلون
الفلسطينيين ولا في رؤيه معاناه
للفلسطينيين هذا واضح جدا هنا وينبغي ان
نؤكد على ذلك
اذا بالنسبه للرئيس بايدن لا يريد ان يرى
الفلسطينيين يقتلون ما يهتم به هو ان نضمن
ان يكون الوضع مستقرا قدر الامكان
بين اسرائيل والفلسطينيين
وهنا ينبغي ان ننظر الى عندما عندما عفوا
سيد ادوارد السيد ادوارد اود ان اقف عند
هذه النقطه سيد ادوارد عندما عفوا
عندما تقول ان اداره الرئيس بايدن لا تريد
لا تريد هذا التصعيد عندما تقول انها لا
تريد هذا التصعيد لماذا لا تعمل على الضغط
من اجل وقفه
دعني ارد على السؤال انهي جوابي واولا ان
اعود الى ما كنت اقوله حول الجهاد
الاسلامي
نتحدث عن
الامريكي الجهاد الاسلام يقول اذا لم
تتوقف العمليه فان المقاومه الفلسطينيه
سوف تفعل ما عليها تفعله في وقت قصير هل
تفهمون ذلك حتى الجهاد الاسلامي
تعطي اسرائيل بعض الوقت ما نتوقعه انه
بدلا من هذا التصريح نتوقع ان تكون يكون
جلسه بقد اطلق صواريخ نحو اسرائيل لم تفعل
ذلك الاسلامي لا يفعل ذلك اذا اذا كان
الجامعي لا يفعل ذلك فلماذا نتوقع من
اداره بايدن
ان تفعل شيئا مختلفا من المؤكد ان هناك
اعتراف فان هنا بان هناك اسلحه
وبكميات
كبيره
وهنا ناتي الى اير
لان الاتهامات الاسرائيليه قد تكون
مشتركه مع الامريكيين تدعم وتمول
محاوله تسليح الضفه الغربيه لايجاد مثل
هذه المصادمات اتضحت الفكره
اتضحت الفكره سيد ادوارد بالحديث هنا عن
الفصائل الفلسطينيه في الوقت الذي تظهر
فيه معطيات عن مشاركه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
معلومات مع الاداره الامريكيه على اعلى
مستوى بشان العمليه العسكريه الجاريه في
جنين لم تغسل المقاومه الفلسطينيه هذا
الجانب من المشهد مسؤول المكتب الاعلامي
لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي قال داوود شهاب قال
ان الموقف الامريكي يوفر غطاء سياسيا
للعدوان الاسرائيلي على جنين المسؤول في
الجهاد اضاف ان موقفا واشنطن تضليل وتزييف
لحقيقه ما يجري على الارض حركه حماس من
قالت ان حديث البيت الابيض عن دعم العدوان
الصهيوني على مخيم جنين يمثل عدوانا على
شعبنا ومشاركه للاحتلال في حربه اعود الى
ضيفنا نوافل عامر من نابلس سيدنا نواف
نقطه مثيره يعني اضاء عليها ضيفنا من
واشنطن كل هذه المواقف عندما يقرا
البيانات بيانات الفصائل الفلسطينيه
يفسرها على انها هي بذاتها تعطي فسحه من
الزمن لاسرائيل لانهاء عمليتها قبل الرد
فلماذا
لوم اداره بايدن على ذلك ما ردك على هذه
النقطه
قبل ان اجيب سيده العزيز يريد ان يكون
يعني السؤال هناك سؤال لضيفك واشنطن السيد
ادوارد عندما يتعلق الموضوع بالدم
الاسرائيلي ان نقي الاري الذي تراه
الاداره الامريكيه وراه الغرب انه دم
مسفوح ونقي تهب امريكا والعالم تستنكر
وتستنجد وتدين بينما تصمت على الدم
والاشلاء الفلسطينيه وتقول انها تعبر عن
قلقها وتراقب عن كثب صحيح ان المثل
الفلسطيني والعام والحكمه العربيه تقول من
راقب الناس ما تهما الا في هذه الحاله
المراقب الامريكي هو يشارك في الجريمه
ويشارك في الدم ويشارك بالقتل وقبل ان
يتحدث السيد ادوارد عن السلاح الايراني في
المنطقه لابد له ان يعلم ان السلاح
الامريكي هو موزع على يعني على غلات
المستوطنين وقام وزير بنجافير بتوصيل هذا
السلاح للمستوطنين الذين يلاحقون ويقتلون
ويح الكره والبلدات ويستهدفون الامنين
اجابه ذلك يعني عندما يتعلق الموضوع
بالفصائل الفلسطينيه الفصائل الفلسطيني لم
تذهب الى قلب تل ابيب انما الجيش
الاسرائيلي جاء الى قلب البدن والى قلب
المخيمات اي اي كلام واي ملاحظات لتغيير
ودفع التهمه عن الاداره الامريكيه بانها
توفر غطاء يعني
للعدوان على اي مكان في الارض الفلسطينيه
انما هو يعني محاوله لمجارات القاتل في
دمه تحت غطاء وتحت مصطلحات فضفاضه تتهم
الفلسطيني بانه صاحب العمل الارهابي بينما
الارهاب الاساسي هو الاحتلال بعينه شكرا
جزيلا لك نواف العامر الكاتب والمحلله
السياسي من نابلس وشكرا لادوه جوزيف
استاذه العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه جونس
هوبكنز كان معنا من واشنط
الى هنا تنتهي حلقتنا من برنامج ما وراء
الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]